انه في بدايه كل يوم تذكر ربنا وتقول
الحمد لله على كل شيء في حياتك
[موسيقى]
هذا بيسبب هشاشه شديد الجلد وهو فيني علمت
ولدت مره وراثي كمان ما له علاج الى الان
مجرد اهتمام بالجروح والفقاعات اللي بتطلع
كمان بيسبب سقف الاسنان تساقط الشعر تساقط
الاظافر
يعني من ابسط دقه ممكن يتجرح تطلع هذه
القاعات زي الحرق في منه ثلاث درجات انا
تقريبا الدرجه من الوسط الشديد عيني فيها
قاعه ملتهبه اليوم صحيت وانام مره تعبانه
منها كمان يدي لها كم يوم يعني ما بقدر
الحمد لله امارس حياتي بالشكل شنو طبيعي
لكن مثلا ما اقدر البس اي نوع قماش المشي
الكثير ممكن يجرح جولي بيتعبني ما اقدر
اني اشيل اشياء ثقيله وحتى ثقيله بالنسبه
للناس العاديه او متعبه بس بالنسبه لي لا
اكثر شيء كمان في الاكل ما أقدر اني اكل
اي شيء لانه صعب الماضي صعب البلع
من اصعب الاشياء اللي انا بوعد فيها دائما
[موسيقى]
ايام المدرسه واجهت تنمر كثير كانوا
يعرفوا في ما عندي صداقات كثيره بس البنات
انه اللي بتخاف تسلم
النظرات من الناس في الاماكن العامه نظرات
استغراب او البعث كان بيتقرف شوي
اكيد كان في تنمر لكن بحاول قد ما اقدر
اني
اتجاهل هذه النظرات واتجاهل هذا التنمر
عشان اقدر اعيش كل يوم جديد هو فرصه لك
وكل يوم هو نعمه عظيمه من الله لك من
اسباب اني انا طلعت السوشيال ميديا اني
ادعم كل شخص مصاب بنفس المرض اللي فيني
وايضا احوالي المصابين خصوصا الاطفال لانه
انا عارفه قد ايش هم
بيتعبوا نفسيا ويكونوا خايفين انه ما في
علاج وهنا ابطال الفراشه حاليا مثلا عندي
جروب في مجموعه كبيره من جميع الدول
العالم العربي في اطفال وكمان في بعض
البنات من عمري مصابين بهذه المرض نساعد
بعض سواء في طريقه الاهتمام او حتى
اجتماعيا معنويا
حابه انه اقول للناس انه اولا هذا المرض
موعدي حاولوا انه انتم تتعاملوا مع
الاشخاص المصابين بمرض انحلال الجلد
الفقاعي بحقك شويه لانه هم بيتقدوا من
ابسط احتكاك